[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
sport l'émission consacrée à l'actualité
sportive dans le département tout de
suite le sommaire de votre magazine
triathlon 120 sportifs ont participé à
la compétition organisée par la commune
de guilde pose ce dimanche au 25 juin
les organisateurs avaient dessiné un
parcours au départ de la piscine
alain mimoun avec 400 m de natation 10
km de vtt 4 km de course à pied plus de
détails à suivre sports extrêmes le mort
fazia luca di meglio tout juste 18 ans
est l'un des plus grands espoirs
français de trottinettes une discipline
qu'il pratique dans les skateparks des
yvelines son portrait retrouver dans
quelques instants
en bas la saison de nationale 2 féminine
s'est terminée début juin pour montigny
le bretonneux lésigny monteyne ont
finalement terminé à la cinquième place
du classement pour faire le bilan des
performances de la saison nous avons
rencontré l'arrière gauche clémence
campagne lieux proposés à trois
questions replants à présent sur les
principaux résultats du week-end dans le
département
[Musique]
on commence donc par une épreuve
d'endurance villepreux n'avait plus
organisé de triathlon depuis à 2009 la
commune a décidé de rectifier le tir ce
dimanche 25 juin au programme du
contre-la-montre de la natation du vtt
de la course à pied dans les espaces
verts de la ville
plus d'une centaine de concurrents après
le départ de l'épreuve les images sont
signés à nicolas d'anglais
une première depuis 2009 villepreux
organisait ce dimanche 25 juin son
triathlon dans les espaces verts de la
commune
la compétition a réuni plus de 120
athlètes novices ou spécialistes de la
discipline
l'objectif c'est s'amuser c'est du vtt
en plus pourquoi faire un pourquoi pas
faire une bonne place aux au classement
général on verra ce que ça donne
j'aime bien relever les défis et
jetterait compétitrices donc voila
c'était un objectif de plus pour pouvoir
participer
pour cette nouvelle formule les
organisateurs avaient dessiné un
parcours au départ de la piscine anna
mimoun avec 400 m de natation 10 km de
vtt 4 km de course à pied
ça se veut vraiment j'allais dire
familiale c'est pas familial mais ça ça
se veut un parcours agréable on va dire
donc voilà c'est passé pas un parcours
difficile
il ya quelques quelques côtes mais bon
voilà malgré tout même si c'est pas des
distances officiel il faut quand même
s'entraîner un minimum bresse que bon
faut tenir sur la distance à l'arrivée
premier réaction
fatigué très fatigué dans sa station ça
brûle de partout là faut que ça j'aurais
bien préféré finir par la piscine mais
ses paroles et prendre une bonne douche
sensation fatigué c'est finalement le
versailles et guillaume henry qui
remporte le contre la montre avec un
temps inférieur à 45 minutes
le triathlète licencié à versailles
réalisé plus de 28 km heure de moyenne
en vtt vu quand on partait sous forme de
contre la montre a pas de stratégie
particulière je sais que mon plus
dangereux concurrent c'était aussi un
gars de versailles qui partait à 8
minutes après fallait que je donne tout
le temps
le sportif tentera de défendre son
encore l'année prochaine une nouvelle
édition devrait être programmée pour
l'été 2010 8
on continue par du baseball les cougars
de montigny le bretonneux jouer ce
week-end au stade jean maréchal contre
les templiers de sénart les deux équipes
sont reparties de leur journée avec une
victoire chacune les y montaient n'en
remporte daisy montain ont remporté le
premier match 4 à 3 mais se sont
effondrées dans le second 18,1 pour
sénart au classement montigny le
bretonneux reste quatrième avec 11
victoires pour 9 défaites
une fois n'est pas coutume nous allons
parler de vtt dans cette émission ce
week-end 179 tête brûlée venus de toute
l'île de france
de normandie ont participé à la 19e
édition de la revancha d'une compétition
organisée comme tous les ans sur la
colline des encours
le concept un parcours de 7 km réputé
pour être l'un des plus compliqués en
ile de france recense près de 210 mètres
de dénivelé avec une cote de 300 m à 15
pour cent pour terminer la course
c'est finalement maxime nguyen de la
team vélo chanel qui a remporté
l'épreuve en 1h 32 sur cinq tours
l'intégralité des bénéfices réalisés
pendant l'opération et rêve est réservée
au profit des eaux des sapeurs pompiers
de france cette année 2008 100 euros
entêté à collecter nous prônons le large
pour parler de voile le versailles et
tanguy de lamotte qui a participé au
dernier vendée globe va mettre entre
parenthèses la compétition au grand
large
un grand large juste après la transat
jacques vabre programmée en novembre
prochain
le sportif de 39 ans va passer la barre
du projet initiative coeur à la
navigatrice samantha davis 42 ans de
vendée globe à son actif
nous avons réussi à joindre par
téléphone tanguy de lamotte pour qu'il
nous explique son choix moi j'avais
envie aussi de faire autre chose donc
j'ai partira vivre à san francisco avec
ma femme et nos deux garçons on a un
petit garçon qu'il n'ya pas très
longtemps donc donc voilà c'est un
tournant dans la vie
et puis c'est un une relance au niveau
professionnel donc vous avez
probablement l'un des des métiers que je
vais y est exercée aux états unis ça
sera le métier d'architecte naval pour
lequel je suis diplômé et c'est la
raison pour laquelle je suis arrivé à la
course au large
donc j'ai envie d'exercer ce métier la
direction les parquets de nba dans ce
magazine l'agencé l'an courtoise
massport agency a vécu jeudi soir
dernier au barclays center de brooklyn
une nuit historique
l'agent olivier mazet a vu l'un de ses
joueurs sous contrat le basketteur
franck ngyke in à être sélectionné en
huitième position pour participer à la
prochaine saison américaine avec la
mythique franchise des new york knicks
le joueur de 18 ans qui évolue et
jusqu'à présent sous les couleurs de
strasbourg devient le français drafté le
plus haut devant son futur coéquipier
joakim noah regarde cette séquence
enregistrée par son agent olivier mazet
il est vrai qu'il s'agit d'une draft
vraiment exceptionnel avec ce huitième
joie qui est tout de même le joueur le
plus au trafic est de l'histoire du
basket français franck unis qui n'a mais
surtout en direction des new york knicks
une franchise mythique et légendaire du
sport américain
donc c'est vrai que l'accumulation de
ces deux facteurs là avec cette draft
historique mais également cette
franchise
voilà tout à fait légendaire une
franchise qui a fait rêver tant de gens
mbiye qui aujourd'hui fait partie des
franchises les plus attractives
médiatiquement nous donne quelque chose
d'absolument incroyable tant pour le
joueur et sa famille on est extrêmement
content de la consécration que ça peut
ça peut avoir par rapport au travail qui
a pu mettre en oeuvre franck mais
également pour nous en tant qu'agent car
c'est quelque chose qui valorise tout
cet investissement on a pu mettre en
place ces deux dernières années et il
est vrai que c'est un succès qu'on
apprécie à sa juste valeur et qui on
l'espère en appelle d'autres
ce n'est pas la première fois que
l'entreprise élan courtoise réussi à
placer l'un de ses joueurs en nba et
déjà l'année dernière gershon yabou
scellés avaient été sélectionnés par les
boston celtics en 16e position
soirée de gala à montigny le bretonneux
la ville organisée vendredi soir les
trophées des sports 2010 est à la ferme
du manet dans sa nouvelle formule
objectif récompenser les acteurs
sportifs de la commune pour clôturer la
saison sportive comme pour les grandes
cérémonies de trophées il y avait des
catégories des nominés et des vainqueurs
le public a également répondu présent
c'était plus de 400 pour applaudir les
sportifs on écoute le maître de
cérémonie le maire de montigny le
bretonneux michel logique les sportifs
chacun reste dans sa discipline et là ce
soir
on se réunit donc on voit qu'aujourd'hui
surmonter ses 152 discipline
différentes et il ya aujourd'hui plein
de belles riches suite
déjà dès le plus jeune âge mais aussi
dans la plupart des
section escadrille aussi c'est comment
thierry ya de réussite du sport féminin
aussi qui est très important la soirée a
également été l'occasion de soutenir la
candidature parisienne aux jeux
olympiques de 2024 pendant l'événement
plusieurs discours et affiches ont été
réalisées sur les gigots pour célébrer
les journées de l'olympisme la ville de
montigny le bretonneux accueillera
notamment les épreuves de bmx et le
cyclisme sur piste au vélodrome
nationale est à la base de loisirs de
saint quentin en yvelines
une autre commune était placé à sous le
signe des jeux olympiques vendredi
dernier je veux bien sûr parler de
versailles la cité royale organisé en
partenariat avec le club d'athlétisme de
la ville une grande journée sportive
au programme de la perche du lancer de
javelot ou encore des courses de la
catégorie cadets à vétérans
une centaine de sportifs a participé à
la manifestation l'écoutent l'une des
organisatrices au micro de patrick
jacques de dixmude
ça nous permet de montrer qu'on est là
qu'on a des athlètes et puis qu'on veut
soutenir la candidature de paris aux jo
2004 alors je sais pas si ça me
permettra de gagner je nous ça peut
montrer justement voilà qu'on est là et
qu'on veut c'est jeux sports extrêmes à
présent coup de projecteur aujourd'hui
sur luca di meglio son nom ne vous dit
peut-être rien et pourtant se mord pas
un de 18 ans est aujourd'hui considéré
comme un as de la trottinette le sportif
participe à de nombreuses compétitions
sportives à travers l'europe
son portrait luca di meglio 18 ans est
addict à la trottinette un sport de
glisse que le mot passe bien pratique en
loisirs depuis sept ans dans les
skateparks des yvelines voisins et
s'acheter une trottinette en fait
en achetant sa trottinette genre je me
suis dit j'ai un défi je me suis dit
serrières pas mal j'ai commencé à
essaimer petit mais première figure
devant chez moi sur mon tir au point
genre j'ai bien kiffé et du coup voilà
c'est comme ça que j'ai attaqué dans la
cantine est aujourd'hui après avoir
appris sur internet link est reconnu
comme un des plus grands riders de
l'hexagone le sportif voyage à travers
l'europe pour participer à des
compétitions là réussi à décrocher la
deuxième place aux montres scooter
conteste en suisse en 2015 l'équivalent
du championnat d'europe des résultats
qui ont attiré les sponsors à partir de
septembre normalement septembre en fin
d'année en année normalement je vais
commencer à être payés par mon pendant
sponsors qui est adx coûteux ring c'est
une marge de profit net pour aller
toujours plus loin dans ses performances
attirer de nouveaux sponsors luca dotto
réinventer tester de nouvelles figures
des prises de risques qui ont failli
briser la carrière du sportif victime
d'une fracture à la cheville droite à 16
ans mais la tête a aujourd'hui gagné en
expérience je sais ce que je peux faire
et je sais ce que je peux pas faire
j'entends je sens vraiment pas quelque
chose je laisse tomber direct mais ça
m'arrive des fois que ne pas sentir
quelque chose est de tenter quand même
au final ça passe tout seul et aux
fenêtres vraiment content après de
l'avoir réussite expérience et
techniques un cocktail explosif qui
pourrait l'amener à décrocher un titre
de champion d'europe l'année prochaine
l'objectif annoncé par luca di meglio
handball féminin la saison de nationale
2 s'est terminée début juin pour monty
le bretonneux après avoir longtemps
côtoyé le bas du classement les signé
montagne qui descendait d'une division
se sont reprises en seconde partie de
saison pour terminer à la cinquième
place du classement
l'objectif fixé en début de saison afin
de dresser un bilan du parcours de
montigny le bretonneux cette saison nous
avons rencontré clémence campagne 23 ans
formé au club nous lui avons posée à
trois questions et a eu des moments très
difficiles surtout pour les joueuses qui
étaient là l'année dernière dont je fais
partie la n1 la redescente taurine de ça
a été très compliqué donc de remobiliser
surtout ses joueuses là qui avait vécu
une saison compliquée de remobiliser
tout le monde et dounia jouer un grand
grand rôle là dedans c'est tout les
jours se sont ressoudés sani quand même
quelques mois et les défaites ont pas
forcément aidé à ça mais à partir du
moment où on a commencé à gagner ça crée
une dynamique assez incroyable
c'était une très très très belle saison
qui a commencé
difficilement ça a été compliqué de
reconstruire le groupe de repartir avec
un nouvel entraîneur le temps prend tout
le monde les bases c'est pas facile on a
eu un petit passage à vide au début et
on a su se remobiliser pour finir en
beauté on a tout explosé à fin de saison
on a su reconstruire le groupe et dans
saison très positive c etais s'etait
génial on n'avait pas envie que ça
s'arrête et
et non c'est pas c'est vraiment très
vite on aurait bien aimé que ça continue
vu la dynamique vivement l'année
prochaine mais qu'on reprenne ça ça peut
être cool
[Musique]
c'est le groupe il y avait je trouve
qu'ils avaient pas une individualité
supérieur aux autres on a su marcher
tout ensemble toutes dans le même sens
voilà je pense que c'est ça qui a fait
notre force était dé toutes ensemble
tout le temps et qui est pas une qui
détache plus que l'autre c'était je
pense que ce qui a fait notre force
c'est vraiment le collectif lui la
saison qu'on a fait cette année ouais
j'ai bon espoir que l'année prochaine se
passe encore mieux que cette raison
[Musique]
l'été approche et les compétitions
sportives se font de plus en plus rares
mais si vous êtes un fan de golf il ya
un rendez vous que vous ne devez pas
manquer la chesnaie open de france est
programmée du 29 juin dimanche le 2
juillet sur les greens du golf national
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines l'événement
pas cette année dans une nouvelle
dimension il a intégré les rolex séries
un cercle de tournois de haut niveau
evènement également vu sa dotation
doublé pour atteindre plus de 6 millions
d'euros ce qui a attiré de nombreuses
têtes d'affiché on écoute paul hermitage
le directeur du golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines tout
parcours de l'albatros il ya du
spectacle avec les quatre trous cantonné
à la fin le 15 16 17 18 qui sont
spectaculaires à tous niveaux
donc oui évidemment il y aura du
spectacle j'espère que les français vont
briller ils sont en forme et ils sont
nombreux ils sont motivés c'est leur
parcours c'est la fin de cette une sport
merci d'avoir suivi très belle soirée
sur tv fil 78
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]